do you want to learn how to stand out
online as social media gets more crowded
are you looking for the best marketing
and money-making strategies for growing
your online business and brand faster
with YouTube and online video if we're
just meeting my name is Sean kennel and
I'm a small-town kid college dropout and
I started making videos in my bedroom
ten years ago alright so this is I guess
the first Sean thinks vlog now this is
definitely as real as it gets so I'm not
gonna try to be energetic or
entertaining fast-forward to today and
I've built a multi-million dollar media
company and that's what inspired this
channel a place where the think media
team and I reveal the marketing and
online business growth strategies that
we've used to scale over the past decade
our mission is to help Purpose Driven
people learn how to build their
influence with YouTube social media and
online video on this channel we're going
to be covering topics like email
marketing paid advertising how to create
and sell digital courses and advanced
strategies for growing your business
faster with social media so make sure to
subscribe every week we will post new
videos including our weekly video
podcast the think marketing show hosted
by Heather Taurus exclusive sessions
from our annual conference grow with
video live in Las Vegas step-by-step
trainings on marketing campaigns funnels
and the best marketing tools and
software and so much more this channel
will help you shorten your learning
curve and simplify the complex world of
online marketing so you can build a
business you love our core values are
Faith Family and legacy and we believe
that there has never been a better time
to build a high impact and high profit
business that not only changes people's
lives but makes a difference in the
world so make sure to hit that subscribe
button and turn on notifications so you
never miss an upload talk soon
[Music]